os produtos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que hoje Vamos destruir o meu iPhone
com esta presença de todos por um
E aí
e o raça foi ultimamente tem sido um ano
por isso eu fui buscar aqui esta prensa
para fazer mais alguns testes aqui no
canal o nosso iPhone conseguiu resistir
a faca quente como vocês viram e hoje
ele vai passar pelo teste da presença de
12 toneladas esta cozinha aqui pequenas
Maga 12 toneladas como é que é possível
vai falar ainda está a funcionar e vamos
lá tá todo estragado aqui ó tá cheio de
cores bué estranhas mas ainda funciona
portanto hoje ele vai passar pelo teste
da prensa hidráulica supostamente isso
funciona tipo com ar eu acho que o ar
vem desde aqui por este cano aqui acima
até esta válvula que deve ter ali óleo
ou água assim e quando a pressão aumenta
ela desce faz força de 12 toneladas e eu
só tenho que ficar assim a bombear e
pastas perguntar que mas como é que isso
volta a subir fácil muito fácil na
introdução à noite tem que essa pequena
válvula que basta fazer assim eu estou
só pois são olha aqui e ele volta a
subir é brutal está explicado o processo
Pessoal vocês já sabem como é que
funciona a presença e agora é o
verdadeiro teste o verdadeiro pé
o iPhone esmagado com a presença
depósito não vale II
E aí outra coisa pessoal quase me
esqueci aqui em cima eu também posso
colocar o tipo uma daquelas que é o que
isto é tipo uma coisa que mede a pressão
que tem aqui dentro mas eu não consegui
por aqui em cima porque esta porca tá
muito apertada ou está muito meu falei
já tentei com chave e com tudo isso não
funcionar é da chave ok olha aí ó
eu gosto muito esta porta não devia
Rodar somente rodar este eu gostava de
ter esta coisa aqui em cima medir o peso
porque isto mede mesma força eu acho que
eu tenho 22 toneladas isso vai ter o
22,22 elefantes um elefante é uma demora
Acho que sim c****** 22 elefantes em
cima de mim mas não vos vamos ter 22
elefantes em cima do iPhone pessoal
agora vamos lá o importante queres
mandar o nosso site vamos fazer o
seguinte Esta é a batida diferença é
primeiro lugar eu vou deixar esmagar o
iPhone assim só para ver o quanto ele
resiste à pressão e depois se resistir
eu vou tentar tomar galo assim ó assim a
força torna-se muito maior daqui como
não a base ele vai me partir aqui no
meio que estão aí vamos tentar fazer vai
lá só ligar pessoal o iPhone Está ligado
né
[Música]
é isso que mora um pouco de escolas tem
uma no ginásio Olha aí só músculos a de
branco e
e isso é o carro de trabalho
e aperta espírito cuidar da frente velha
se o pacote Oscar o iPhone Olha aí ó tá
muito perto já eu vou ligar o iPhone vou
tentar só manter ligado aqui a ponta
aqui a produção então está aqui ou está
quase a chegar o iPhone está muito quase
tá muito quase só você entrar um pouco
aqui ok tem que ser exatamente no meio
aqui assim preciso de uma espécie de
Cristo pode dar explosão é preciso mudar
agora vai agora vai. Aqui pronto agora
já chegou já chegou traz uma carne traz
lagarto será queimado o olha olha olha
vida. Aberto
Bom dia Carol porém o vírus macaco estou
a fazer tipo parece está respirando meu
olha aí ó
eu juro de ouvido oh my god eu estou
aqui não estou não estou aqui deste lado
estado mais meu eu vou vir aqui ó
o filme continua a funcionar como é que
é possível isso funcionar assim tá
aparecer uma televisão estragada Olha
isso não é uma televisão estragada eu
tenho quase a certeza que se for uma
loja comsertao eu acho que dá para
consertar porque isso é só o ecrã do
iPhone já passou por faca quente o
iPhone já passou por presença não foi de
12 toneladas mas foi tipo de que eu vou
com umas quatro calhar quando não Umas
três uma uma tonelada pagar uma uma pele
também o Marcelo também viu agora
pessoal vamos tentar de outra maneira
meu assim vai assim vai falei assim vai
filmar e produção são aí fome aqui OK Tá
mesmo quase pessoal tá ali mesmo quase
Olha aí a ponta aqui a produção Olha aí
embaixo embaixo embaixo Aqui aqui
embaixo aqui embaixo frente mesmo Olha
aí falta só um pouquinho mesmo já chegou
já chegou já chegou ou chega Oi ouviram
falar mãe rapaz tudo o
a outa dobrado é
e ainda o Google como é que lembra liga
vai dobrar mais já desligou o Natal em
casa assim olha aqui olha como é que tá
aqui do lado medo que já tá tudo torto
aqui agora vou soltar o Facebook
eu vou
e vejam Como está ele ainda liga como é
que linda liga como é que vai for eu só
olhei então dobrado aqui no meu Bora mas
tu não lado agora ó
eu só gosto do meu relógio novo aí agora
Agora é sem piedade vamos até o fim até
o iPhone dobrar Olha aí só vai só vai
vai parte no meio vamos lá pudim olha aí
ó
E o Pedro tá assaltado veja um vídeo
assaltar ali olha aqui essa ponta mais
peso Bora lá oi vou vou tá muito
namorado o vídeo tá solta por todo lado
tu estás com a bateria corrente de não
se só vai só pai peso peso peso Olha aí
tá ligado tá ligado como assim que tá
ligado aí eu disse que isso é fora do
Hoje vou assim ó
e aqui já tá tudo aberto hoje até está a
sair o outro foi para tentar outra coisa
vamos tentar em direito agora agora
vamos ter que fazer a dobra ao contrário
vou soltar um pouco
o ok Acho que sim chega né É
e olha aí tô indo deitar vai digitando o
que se faz tudo o que tu fala vou
retirar a força agora
[Música]
e ele ainda está ligado não é
a multa o fogo já não liga eu já estou
preparado aqui Vejam Só o que aconteceu
o iPhone posso Parou tudo aqui já não
liga agora sim eu já não liga eu tenho
uma dobra dos dois lados eu vou tentar
arrancar agora essa parte
o disco todo a bateria tá chegar a
queimado por acaso Oi fez foi um visto
chega tipo atóxico e eu vou morrer Aqui
está a nossa iPhone Vamos tentar só a
partir do ecrã agora agora a bateria tem
que por dentro de um saco e mandar para
um especial se não estou Isso aqui vai
arrebentar em algum a321 vai tá quase a
partir já é
e vai parte 1
e o seu fumo da Se fuma aqui oi Será que
é o cd dele eu não sei mas tem o filme
de lá vai se passa alta rebentou tudo já
Olha aí até dobrou em dois quantas Chapa
meu agora eu duvido que dá para
consertar né então é isso pessoal vem
buscar por aqui com ele como assim estou
Nossa Senhora mano porque estás me ligar
mas não só na brincadeira o que isso não
funciona isso aí pessoal vamos ficar
aqui com este vídeo esta foi a
destruição do nosso iPhone 6 na nossa
presença de doce de um lado e já sabem
Esmague o botão do like e alho e comenta
e coisas para eles mandar aqui na prensa
eu acho
é com muita coisa portanto comentei
coisas tipo sei lá um ovo um boneco
qualquer coisa que possa Jesus em muito
meu comenta só que eu vou te mandar com
esta presença de duas toneladas e é isso
como que eu posso like aqui do lado
vocês vão ter dois filhos para assistir
e aqui em cima vocês podem subscrever
tem um Feliz Natal para todos pessoal é
Natal Avon se divertir vão comer muito é
isso fiquem bem e até a próxima um
E aí